let's go next to our caller from the
nine one seven area code who's calling
today from nine one seven hello yeah
that's you in regards to like what are
your thoughts on like I've been noticing
a lot of supposed liberal people like
Atma leftist that are pushing this
rushing like anti-russia gate gang okay
to be doing all that like I'm just
curious what that's all night do you
find that incredibly damaging are they
I'm still doing it I mean listen I don't
watch I don't watch my liberal shows but
it's I thought that they were done with
that because the we got the molar report
already didn't we
well pushing the whole like anti like
maybe I'm not explaining it right but
like yeah just pushing like that it's a
conspiracy and it's a big failure and
when I just find it really bizarre that
anyone on the left or anyone that's like
just not a trump supporter and kind
would be like but with totally ignore
which is probably the biggest scandal I
would say in modern US history so yeah I
mean listen I can't speak to what the
motivations are for what other shows do
you know I don't really watch them but
at this point I don't even know like
what I guess people could say oh it was
all overblown from the beginning or
something like that but it's like listen
we got a report that was extremely
damaging to the president he has
successfully kind of inoculated himself
from consequences and we'll see if
reelection continues to keep him
inoculated but we had you know
convictions indictments prison time
Donald Trump found to have behaved meet
all three criteria for obstruction on I
think it's eight of fourteen possible
obstructive acts I don't know I mean
listen there's not any news related to
it right now so I'm not even talking
about it I don't know what it is that
people are like what is it I don't even
know what there is to cover about it at
this point you know but again I can't I
don't want to judge what other shows are
doing if I haven't seen it okay I
appreciate that and it's like that one
other question yeah and I'm sure other
people are thirsty
what insured you might have heard or
seen clips or what did he see that Dave
Rubin toasty interview I did I did and
you know I've not covered it only
because I've not had the emotional
willpower to sit through it all to pull
the clips but it was basically a
combination that it struck me as Dave
Rubin doing exactly what the debate
moderators have done so far which is key
questions up with right-wing framings
and then Tulsi Gabbard answering them
buying into those right-wing framings
rather than pointing out that the
questions themselves are a huge part of
the problem it was really bad from what
I saw
yeah I'm just curious like where she
obviously she know she's not gonna get
the nomination you would think I mean it
will only someone who is completely
deluded would be polling 1% and not even
in all of the debates anymore and
believing that they're going to be the
president or even the nominee I assume
you're right about that I just think
that it's not even that I think she's
like angling for something else either
some kind of spoiler third party rod who
the hell knows some desert Trump like
last-minute thing grabbing her putting
you know like so I just found that way
now before your realties angling to be
to replace Mike Pence's Trump's running
mate
I think that might be a little bit
extreme you know there's always been
little tells with total see over the
years like especially like with her
tweets and like oh we got a support
Trump like immediately after he
announced being one know little things
like that that their little red herrings
about her I always noticed there anytime
you mentioned something bad about her
the people that usually come out and so
forth yeah on Twitter or not people on
the left yeah man I hate my hatred mail
episode this week was from a Tulsi
Capote supporter which is crazy because
usually it's just like right-wing clowns
that send a hatred mail but all right I
appreciate the phone call thank you
thank you all right take care